hi in this video I will talk about the
difference between LTP and Ltd
difference between long-term
potentiation versus long-term depression
now first I would talk about the
experimental schemes that people have
done so most of the recordings
electrophysiological recordings have
been done in in Mouse train here they
cut a coronal section if you cut a
coronal section to something look like
this and they would place the coronal
section in electrophysiological rig
under a microscope and here they would
put the coronal section and they can
supply artificial cerebrospinal fluid
which would keep that preparation alive
maintain a physiological condition
underline that situation you can see
they can start recording
here is the recording electrode other
side which is not shown is a stimulating
electrode they can stimulate from one
side they can record the responses from
other side here you can see a deicing
image of the neurons where they are
started recording now they have
stimulating electrode they can use they
can inject current and they can inject
current of different frequencies they
can stimulate at a hundred Hertz
frequency which is a very high frequency
underlying this kind of high frequency
stimulation they have found that over
time synaptic strength has increased and
the readout is increase in synapse
increase in epsp slope than the baseline
whereas in case of a low frequency
stimulus which lasts for about 10
minutes prolonged low frequency stimulus
can give rise to depression in synaptic
strength so depending upon the frequency
of stimulation there could be different
outcomes one lead to strengthening other
lead to weakening and there is a
bidirectionality to it now
the question is what is so special about
this stimulation frequency what is the
molecular mechanism underlying this
stimulation frequency which can give
rise to strengthening or weakening in a
context dependent manner
so before that we should understand what
happens just underlying this high
frequency or low frequency stimulation
when we give a high frequency stimulus
about hundred Hertz for one second
it would allow calcium entry via NMDA
receptor and the calcium entry via NMDA
receptor is drastic it's dramatic huge
amount of calcium get in from the NMDA
receptor which would increase the
calcium level ten folds from 100
nanomolar to one micromolar whereas in
case of low frequency stimulation about
hundred Hertz for five to fifty minutes
people have found that calcium enters
calcium enters slowly and and the
resting calcium of 100 nanomolar get
increased and maintained at a level of
400 nano molar to 500 nanometer which is
not as high as found in case of high
frequency stimulation the high frequency
stimulation the the brief and high
amount of calcium level has different
implication than a prolonged sustained
level of calcium so clearly you can
understand that if you give a
high-frequency stimulation
you could have synaptic strengthening
whereas a low frequency stimulus can
give rise to synaptic weakening both at
structural and functional level here
it's shown that a structural level after
Ltd protocol the the synaptic size has
decreased now what are the molecular
mechanisms underlying that one of the
striking molecular mechanism by which
the functional chain alteration happens
is by endocytosis of ample receptors
underlying high frequency stimulus
calcium level rise drastically where our
decoder molecules which can decode the
calcium spatial temporal dynamics and
can give rise to the ultimate result is
to displaying more and more ample sector
to the postsynaptic membrane whereas in
case of Ltd where you give low frequency
stimulus the
level of calcium intermediate level of
calcium is maintained for a long
duration and that ultimately give rise
to internalization of the AMPA receptors
reducing the ampere current they are by
reducing the total postsynaptic
potential and thereby reducing the
synaptic strength now here you can see
that here is the epsp
it's a baseline epsp that you can record
after a high frequency stimulus you are
going to record a boosted response
whereas the scenario is opposite in case
of a low frequency stimulation which
give rise to synaptic depression so
clearly the mystery lies in spatial
temporal dynamics of calcium a brief and
high level of calcium can give rise to
potentiation or increase in synaptic
strength whereas a sustained low level
of calcium can give rise to depression
like phenomenon the question is how this
spatial temporal dynamics of the calcium
is read out inside the cell so clearly
we need decoder molecules which can
decode the message inside the calcium
dynamics and two most popular decoder
molecules that I would discuss is Cam k2
which can kind of decode the message
which is inside the fast calcium
dynamics which lasts about a second and
it's an amplitude of 100 nano thousand
animal are about a micro molar whereas
low level of calcium is detected by
calcium unit which is a phosphatase
but how can k2 they just first
understand how cam k2 can read out this
kind of dynamics and after reading
calcium how it can write the plastic
changes so recent experiment by Rijo you
shootas lab has shown that with with
thread sensors they have specifically
engaged glutamate into specific synapses
and thereby they can activate specific
synapses a particular synapse they can
active but the nearby synapse won't be
activated in this scenario and they have
a genetically encoded
sense
of chemical activity sitting in the post
synapse they have found that camp k2
activity persist for about a minute and
just after camp into activity there is a
correlative increase in the synaptic
volume or the spine size but this
scenario is only true when they
repetitively give 40 to 50 pulses a
single pulse does not give optimum
activity of the camp k2 and does not
translate to a volume change or a
functional change that means a sudden
high level of calcium is important for
gamma key to optimal camp k2 activity
and thereby structural and functional
changes low level of calcium level of
calcium or low frequency stimulus cannot
give that necessary drive to activate
cam k2 optimally exactly if we talk
about cam video cam k2 is a dodok aware
of 600 kilo Dalton molecular weight and
and cam k2 has 12 subunits each subunit
need to get phosphorylated and this
phosphorylation is boosted when calcium
and cannot a limb by into camp k2 but
this is not the only process there are
phosphatases which is always trying to
remove the phosphate groups from the
camp k2 and thereby inhibiting it now
there is a competition between kinase
and phosphate phosphatase activity when
there is a huge amount of calcium
persisting for for very less amount of
time the kinase activity is out
competing the phosphatase activity and
thereby optimally activating calculative
then once cam video is activated it can
give rise to structural change which is
recorded by spine volume increase and
also it can increase the postsynaptic
current or postsynaptic potential and
this is restricted to the spine which is
stimulated and this kind of response is
not found in a nearby spine and you
should the Stroop shown it beautifully
now what exactly happening why cam k2
requires a high level of calcium it has
been shown that campitos
game value is pretty high that means
affinity towards calcium and calmodulin
is pretty low whereas another
phosphatase calcineurin has very high
and thereby it has a very low cane now
modeling studies have shown that that
can get to activity persist for long
time whereas calcineurin activity
doesn't persist for a long time now we
can clearly understand the biophysics of
detection if you have prolonged low
level of calcium it could be detected by
calcium you in like phosphatases and the
kinase activation could give could be
done when there is high and brief brief
and high level of calcium so and these
biophysics of detection is true across
several synapses in several brain
regions but the point lies that how can
k2 and calcium interacts with other
molecular players so depending upon how
they interact with our the molecular
players it would give rise to
potentiation or depression now we talked
about this artificial protocol which can
alter the synaptic strength but the
question is whether long-term depression
or potentiation like phenomena is true
underlying learning paradigms or is it
the same mechanism used by the brain
while they are trying to store or
consolidate memory people have shown
that underlying specific inhibitory
avoidance training where Mouse is when
that is whether a mouse is actually
trained to avoid a particular dark box
where they get a shock underlying this
kind of paradigm training paradigm that
will found that certain neurons have
elevated their v their epsp slope that
means that their their post synaptic
strength was potentiated increased and
that lasted for hours in case of
Drosophila there are evidences were
under aversive conditioning there is a
depression happening in specific
synapses in the fly Learning Center and
in between the fly learning center the
mushroom body neurons and the mushroom
body output neurons people have found
that underlying aversive training which
is just a
conditioning where the fly is trained
with order a and given a shock they're
associated they're associating this
order with shock otherwise they're
trained with another order P where the
shock is not given now only order a and
B is given now if they have learnt their
lesson they would avoid the ordered a
because if they know it comes with a
shock underlying this kind of training
people have found that the relevant
circuits in in specific element of the
relevant circuit there is the depression
of the synaptic strength now it's still
unclear that how sometimes synaptic
depression or synaptic potentiation can
encode exactly memory but definitely
this kind of protocol has good
computational advantages which I have
discussed in other videos and that's why
people think that this kind of
mechanisms could be used by our brain to
encode memory a recent study by molinos
lab has shown that that brain actually
used this kind of LTP and Ltd like
protocol to encode memory and they have
a simple paradigm then again did a
classical conditioning paradigm of that
valerian conditioning when a mouse is
associated when a mouse is represented
to our tone and while they give up they
are given a shock so the tone is
conditioned stimulus and the shock is
unconditioned stimulus shock is
unconditioned stimulus because shock is
painful to them when whenever you give
the shock the mouse would the mouse
would freeze but next time if you
associate both of them and then you only
represent the tone if the mouse has
learned lesson it would freeze when the
tone is represented alone and now they
know exactly the how this tone is
actually represented in the brain by the
auditory cortex neurons so they can
replace the tone by activating those
neurons in the auditory cortex now they
have an optical conditioned stimulus now
what they have observed that the
underlying conditioning there is certain
increase in AMPA by NMDA ratio which is
a signature of increasing synaptic
strength not only that after a paired
conditioning where the mouse is
to pair the shock with the tone after
that using that optogenetic set up they
give low frequency stimulation thus
applying a DD protocol and it's reduced
the memory of the fear conditioning so
the mouse would be freezing when it is
it is actually when it has fear it has a
memory of fear it would freeze and it
won't it won't press a liver which is
there in the Cayman to deliver food in
normal condition whenever it presses a
lever it would get a food but when it is
afraid it won't press the liver so
number of liver pressing is almost zero
when it is scared so this is a readout
for its fear memory but this numb the
fear the the fear associated behavioral
signature is gone once they have applied
an Ltd protocol after one day they have
applied a long-term potentiation
protocol a high frequency stimulus
protocol and the form that memory came
back again they have done an Ltd
protocol they saw the mouse is no more
freezing when the tone is presented that
means the fear memory is gone so their
bye-bye off just after preparing they
can give non-stop potentiation and
long-term depression protocol to write
and erase memories but also their
research have shown that FTP or Ltd and
alone not sufficient to evoke the memory
that means LTP and Ltd kind of protocol
can give rise to plastic changes at the
cellular level but might not be encode
might not LTP and Ltd protocol can
encode memory and it requires a pairing
event after that ldpr Ltd protocol can
give rise to memory life changes so that
also argues that LTP like protocol could
be one of the features by which brain
can encode memory underlying that could
be underlying
LPB protocol is not exactly memory but
still these areas are debated and more
research is required to reveal the truth
so if you like my video please subscribe
give it a big thumbs up and don't forget
to share thank you